por pura diversión vamos a aproximar el
área que queda por debajo de la gráfica
de la función f x igual a raíz de x1 en
el intervalo 16 es decir vamos a
aproximar el área de esta región de aquí
que estoy sombreando va deja mejorar
esto que acabo de poner y para realizar
esta aproximación lo que vamos a
utilizar son 5 trapecios 5 trapecios
trapecios con el mismo largo vamos a ver
cuánto tendría que ser este largo va
pues mira tenemos que avanzar de 1 a 6
entonces tenemos que avanzar 6 menos 1
unidades o sea 5 y esas tenemos que
repartir las equitativamente 5 en 5
trapecios entonces el largo de cada uno
de los trapecios de 55 que es igual a 1
déjame ponerle un nombre a esto vamos a
llamarle delta x que es 1 y entonces
delta x es es justo 1 verdad bueno
entonces vamos a dibujar nuestros 5
trapecios para ver cómo quedarían
nuestro primer trapecio empieza aquí en
el 1 entonces su altura aquí del lado
izquierdo su lado
izquierdo sería f 1 que es 0 y su lado
derecho sería f 2 déjame marcar aquí efe
2 y de hecho este trapecio es un poco
curioso verdad este trapecio más bien es
un triángulo pero está bien no sea es un
trapecio degenerado es un caso especial
de trapecio en el cual uno de los lados
mide 0 déjame marcar esta área así la
voy a sombrear así con naranja vamos al
segundo trapecio el segundo trapecio es
de este lado tendrían altura fdf 2 y acá
tendría de altura entre 3 entonces voy a
pintar aquí entre 3 de altura y
tendríamos algo más o menos de este
estilo va este sería el segundo trapecio
el tercer trapecio misma idea de este
lado tiene efe de 4 de altura de este
lado tiene efe de 3 entonces sus lados
paralelos miden efe de 3 y fv 4 y el
área el área sería ésta de acá sería
esta región
vamos con el tercer trapecio el tercer
trapecio sube hasta acá un lado paralelo
bueno uno de los lados paralelos mide
efe de cuatro y el otro mide efe de
cinco entonces tendríamos un trapecio de
esta forma y finalmente el último y
quinto trapecio lo voy a poner aquí con
color rojo y misma idea vale entonces
tenemos esta altura
qué es efe de 6 tenemos esta otra altura
que ese f de 5 entonces los de los lados
paralelos miden f 5 y f de 6 y queremos
calcular esta área de acá excelente
entonces justo vamos a hacer esto vamos
a calcular el área de cada uno de estos
trapecios y vamos a sumar todas esas
áreas para obtener nuestra aproximación
vamos con el primer trapecio triángulo o
trapecio degenerado bueno vamos a
utilizar la fórmula de área de trapecio
para ver que también funciona en este
caso aunque nos quede un triángulo va
entonces cuál sería el área de este
trapecio pues tendríamos que promediar
sus lados paralelos nos quedaría f1 f2
entre 2
y luego tendríamos que multiplicar por
la distancia entre los lados por delta x
fíjate aquí no hay problema porque como
f1 es cero como f 10 nos queda f 2 por
delta equis o sea altura por base
dividido entre 2 es el área de un
triángulo está padre verdad la fórmula
de área para trapecio también funciona
para trapecios degenerados para
triángulos bueno pasemos con el segundo
que ya no es tan emocionante pero igual
está padre nos quedaría el promedio de
los lados paralelos
efe de 273 entre 2
entre 2 x el largo que delta x con el
tercer trapecio tenemos algo similar f3f
de 4 dividido entre 2
este es el promedio de los lados
paralelos multiplicado por la distancia
entre esos lados más ahora vamos con el
trapecio verde ya ya se ve la idea
verdad
efe de 4
más de 5 dividido entre 2 dividido entre
2 por delta equis y finalmente el último
creo que no va a caber por acá entonces
voy a ponerlo tantito abajo sería f 5f
de 5 + +
efe de 6 dividido entre 2 dividido entre
2 x la distancia entre los lados
paralelos por delta x muy bien entonces
estoy acá ya es nuestra aproximación y
pues recuerda en realidad si es una
aproximación ahorita la simplificamos
porque se puede simplificar todos tienen
delta x entre 2 pero antes de eso déjame
recordar que todo esto es nada más una
aproximación aquí parece estar una
aproximación muy buena aquí se parece se
pega muchísimo a la gráfica de la
función pero tenemos que recordar que en
realidad no es así en realidad sobran
cachitos aquí sobra tantito
aquí sobra tantito y sobra tantito por
todas partes sobre tantito sin aunque no
parezca sobra un cachito entonces esta
es una aproximación para el área déjame
escribirlo así esto de aquí es el área
aproximada área aproximadamente es igual
a esto y ahora sí vamos a simplificar un
poquito para ver que nos queda entonces
esto es igual a vamos a factorizar el
delta x entre 2 de esta x entre 2 ya
todo lo voy a poner con este color crema
para para no andar cambiando de colores
y vamos a ver que nos quedaría dentro
del paréntesis pues ve nos queda un f1
nos queda un f1 luego hay que sumar aquí
hay un f de 2 y aquí hay otro f de 2
entonces son dos veces ejes de 2 2 veces
f de dos más también nos queda dos veces
f de tres y lo estoy escribiendo de esta
manera porque así lo escriben en los
libros y en los libros se escriben esta
fórmula que ahorita voy a terminar de
escribir pero pero bueno ahorita
hablamos un poco de eso vamos a seguirle
dos veces efe de cuatro
más dos veces efe de cinco más
efe ya nada más una vez para más de seis
entonces esto es para cinco trapecios
pero si lo quisiéramos hacer en general
pues hay que sumar una vez
efe en el extremo izquierdo y una vez
efe en el extremo derecho y todo lo
demás todo lo que queda en medio la efe
evaluar en esos puntos se repite dos
veces para bueno estás aquí en la
formulita yo no soy un gran fan de que
le escriban directamente en los libros
así sin dar explicaciones porque no te
dice a qué se refiere si no está muy
padre éste verlo así de golpe pero pues
teniendo este dibujo uno entiende mucho
más qué es lo que está sucediendo bueno
bueno
ya con esto en mente vamos a evaluar si
sabemos quién es delta xy conocemos cuál
es la función entonces vamos a cambiar
ahora sí todo esto por numeritos para
ver cuánto nos queda este delta x es un
1 afuera nos queda un medio efe de uno
es cero eso ya lo platicamos cuando
vimos lo del triángulo pero se ve aquí
arriba verdad
efe de uno es raíz de cero
verdad entonces nos queda 0 aquí es dos
veces f 2 si ponemos aquí 2 nos queda a
raíz de 1
entonces nos quedaría este 2 nada más
ver a 2 x raíz de 1 y nos quedaría 2 x
raíz de dos porque metemos 3 y nos queda
la raíz de dos metiendo 4 en esta
expresión nos queda raíz de tres
entonces sería dos veces raíz de tres
metiéndose 5 nos queda raíz de 4 que es
2 x este 2 es un 4 2 por dos es cuatro y
finalmente hay que hacer
efe de seis ya nada más una vez entonces
nos vamos acá
efe de 6 es raíz de 5 bueno entonces nos
queda aquí raíz de 5 excelente esto de
aquí es la aproximación así en términos
de raíces pero pues para encontrar un
numerito vamos a meter esto a la
calculadora a ver cuánto nos da exacta
la cálculo
déjame déjame prenderla ok y hay que
multiplicar 0.5 ese es el un medio por
voy a abrir paréntesis por 0 más bueno
el 0 no tenía que ponerlo pero lo pongo
para saber en dónde voy más 2 más 2 por
raíz de 2
cierro paréntesis de la raíz más 2 por
raíz de 3
cierro paréntesis de la raíz más 44 más
raíz de 5 cierro paréntesis de la raíz y
cierro el paréntesis de la
multiplicación de afuera y eso nos queda
redoble de tambores este numerito de acá
de 7.26 429 luego ya lo voy a este
redondear como 7.26 vale 12 7.26 el área
es aproximadamente igual a 7.26 muy bien
entonces aquí ya tenemos un numerito y
esta área es una aproximación para el
área por debajo de la gráfica de esta
función entonces con esto aproximamos el
área por debajo de la función fx igual a
raíz d
1 en el intervalo 16 y esto lo logramos
utilizando una aproximación con 5
trapecios